hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast thursday live stream edition
back from here and there and everywhere
it is episode 127 which i'm just gonna
guess is prime
it is all right i knew that it was prime
because we checked just before going on
but nonetheless it remains prime whether
i cheated or not it's it's true it's
true
um so it's been a while since we've been
here we're going to be here today no q a
today and we're going to come back to
you in in less than two days actually on
saturday at our normal time
and uh joined then perhaps as well by
our our smallest panther tesla uh and um
we'll be coming back to you on saturdays
for um for a bit after a lot of strange
scheduling
um
announcements i guess
um
what do we got well um our
our private q a also our private q a
which you can access at my patreon is
this sunday so we're doing this right
now on thursday we're going to have
another live
stream uh along with a public q a on
saturday and then on sunday at 11 a.m
pacific there will be a private q a so
if you're interested in that you can
join us there at my patreon find the
link there
um
boy there's just a lot of other things
to say but maybe maybe we'll well maybe
they'll happen in line or maybe they'll
happen online i will say um don't
hesitate to spread the word check and
see whether you're still subscribed we
see a lot of funny business on this
channel
and um you know frankly i think it
suggests that uh goliath may have wised
up and decided to do some uh
some subtler things so anyway
subtler um so anyway it's worth checking
checking whether you're still subscribed
and
you know doing all the things you might
to help us out algorithm wise yeah
um we we appreciate all of it we
appreciate your support by uh showing up
and listening the the
the wonderful uh fan mail that we
receive both you know through email and
through letters and just being stopped
in the street honestly
it's pretty pretty remarkable um but
also subscribing to this channel to the
clips channel liking the videos you like
sharing them and of course if you have
the wherewithal and um interest in
supporting us financially if you can
through for instance patreon
but also the um the
much of the way that we are supporting
this work right here is through our
sponsors whom we are very grateful to
and for and
and hat and
with with we are grateful with them for
all of the wonderful bounty that is this
earth that we share
well i think that was pretty good for on
the spot abs absolutely absolutely um a
tesla say i'm in though tesla is
nonplussed
no i think he's plus i was just going to
say i've never seen him plus never seen
you plus never seen anyone plus honestly
i know it's it's uh
it may be that it's a flammable
inflammable situation where they both
just mean the same thing it sounds
better with the prefix yeah um but i
don't i don't know what blust is
yeah i don't either i've been minused a
few times sure yeah absolutely no that's
kind of that's your want
not what you want right is your want
yeah i almost got minused over a uh
the pre-takeoff tweet which i did not
realize was going to be at all
controversial well i think uh i think
pre-takeoff tweets are just setting
yourself up for those those who would
imagine that they now have many many
hours depending on in this case it was a
transatlantic flight uh to which they
didn't know presumably uh to you know to
really to really get in there it was a
transcendental flight was it you didn't
mention that to me how are you how are
you transformed uh i well i came back
the other direction so you know it's a
reversible reaction and chemically
speaking i am what i was before but i
wasn't in the intro in so many ways not
what that means
okay but do they know that i think so
i think so i think so uh so yeah we are
um very discriminating in the sponsors
that we accept
it is the fifth anniversary plus a few
days of us being accused of that exact
thing
we are discriminating and we are
discerning about which sponsors uh we we
accept and actually speaking of the
fifth anniversary of evergreen like
maybe we should talk about some about
that today um there are two things
before we get into our three ads for the
hour
um
you did a five-year anniversary
conversation with benjamin boyce
who was also on the ground
during during the events there we came
to know him a week or two afterwards
we'd never met him before evergreen blew
up i became aware of him
during what must have been his first or
maybe just
first or second broadcast
from the library which he did in
portrait because everybody else from
evergreen who filmed the damn thing did
it in portraits so it became so he
didn't landscape you mean he'd no he did
it portrait just to be in keeping with
everybody else's terrible video
technique so how did that do how did
that discriminate him from the others it
didn't that was him fitting in and then
him saying things that were true is what
separated him i see yeah i see
uh yeah well i first came to know um
benjamin and i thought at the time you
would indicate to me that this was this
was news to you as well that um
he was one of the 17 people 17 students
at the time who signed the letter saying
you know what the [ __ ] is going on here
excuse me but you know like hello
evergreen administration and faculty and
students and all y'alls uh this is
insane and this is not what we stand for
and uh those i and i that letter went
out and i figured out we didn't know any
of them those were none of those were
our students um and i figured out um who
most of them were uh through channels
that were then available to us as
evergreen faculty and wrote a letter to
all of them
and uh and asked anyone who knew the
couple that who i couldn't find um to
spread it and benjamin was one of the
ones i had found and he wrote back and
and you know so a friendship was born
you know he was he was really
you know extraordinary from the
beginning
so anyway i had completely forgotten
that he was a signatory to that letter
but i at least became aware of him from
his library broadcast which is pretty
cool it's worth going back and looking
at um to see what it looked like for a
um
a recent grad i guess to be
or was he just on the verge of gravity
yeah i know he was not graduated yet he
was i think i've been the week before or
something
no i mean graduation happened three or
four weeks afterwards right this was
that that whole thing happened in like
week seven of a 10-week quarter week
eight it was it was
eight or nine anyway it doesn't matter
it was right at the end of the quarter i
know that because bob woodson offered to
come out
and uh stand shoulder to shoulder with
us which would have been ebay week but
that was several weeks later yeah and it
wasn't clear that there would have been
anything to
so i've actually just written about some
of this which is the other thing that
we're gonna that i just wanted to
mention as the as the anniversary god
there's a lot of fur dust or birds in
the air or something
um
so my natural selections uh post for
this week is about the five year
anniversary and one of the things i
mentioned
i didn't mention him my name because i
didn't have time before i wrote it to to
say who it was but i when i say in there
a civil rights activist who had marched
with king
had reached out to you and said i would
like for myself and to bring a few other
of my of my civil rights activist
buddies to come and march on the
evergreen campus with you and heather
and um and we were considering it and
then violence emerged anew uh basically
when um
i think it was when uh the patriot
prayer group came and they did not bring
any violence to campus but there was
violence around them that was made to
look like it was them
so
we had to say there's there's no there's
no way to march on campus at this point
all right
um
maybe we should move on to
paying the rent and then we can either
return to evergreen or we can
um
move on to other topics okay all right i
guess i'm number one yes you are this
might be the first time that's happened
nope
[Music]
all right this is not the first time
i've been the first one on thecube but
it's been a while right
i don't know probably yes
okay
uh our first sponsor this week is moink
m-o-i-n-k
97 of the chickens served in the u.s are
dipped in chlorine this is because a big
egg doesn't have the same quality
standards as the family farm an eighth
generation farmer founded moiq
that's
moo plus oink
yes i knew that but had forgotten
so you can help save the family farm and
get access to the highest quality meat
on earth mike delivers grass-fed
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild-caught alaskan
salmon direct to your door moik farmers
farm like your grandparents did well not
my grandparents but probably your
grandparents my grandpa my grandparents
your grandpa mm-hmm my grandparents did
fine even your your dad for a time well
i was a child yes well he's still
farming it counts
he left as soon as he could
as a result moiq
meat tastes like it should which is to
say delicious unlike the supermarket
moink gives you total control over the
quality and source of your food you
should choose the meat delivered in
every box like rib eyes to chicken
breasts pork chops to salmon fillets and
much more i'm gonna interrupt for a
second
while you were gone um
this last week the boys and i had a um
flank steak from wike and it was
spectacular it was spectacular i'll just
add that in here all right yeah that's
um i hear there was a flank steak had
while i was gone that was spectacular
was it spectacular zach to me this is
hearsay but i i believe it it was
actually see all right well there's
testimonials going on all over this is
what happens when you leave yeah well we
have spectacular
because we sit around doing testimonials
yeah okay
all right could you film that next time
because i'm not quite sure what that
would mean
all right um we love everything about
mike the fact that the meat is grass-fed
and finished on small farms the lovely
publications that come along with it and
of course the meat itself
uh shark tank host kevin o'leary called
moyk's bacon the best bacon he had ever
tasted we agree it is amazing and the
fling steak and the flank steak yeah i
mean the bacon but the flank steak wow
keep american farming going by signing
up at the moinkbox.com
dark horse right now and listeners of
this show will receive free filet mignon
for a year that's one year of the best
filet mignon you've ever tasted but for
a limited time
spelled moic m-o-i-n-k box dot com slash
darkhorse that's mikebox.com
dark horse
and i have a retraction to make it uh-oh
um no not really just um
my father's father who was the far the
main farmer and the farm owner in
northeast iowa where my father grew up
along with his siblings and his
his parents didn't grow up there
my father's father encouraged all of his
children to leave the farm because he he
saw
what as it turns out was largely true at
least in that part of iowa which was an
increasing sort of corporatization of
farmlands and at this point it's all you
know giant i think largely pig farms at
this point they were raising cows and
and pigs and chickens and vegetables and
um and you know all sorts of things but
um
my father uh became a computer engineer
and i think it was absolutely the right
move he was he was a much more much more
of a natural as a computer engineer uh
than as a farmer but he used to call
himself a little country programmer
when he first he went to notre dame and
then to pittsburgh and then la which is
uh where where i knew him most yeah he
became a code farmer a code farmer
all right our second sponsor of uh and
he i'm sure so he's he's gone now but i
am certain that he would love the food
from white because he was
always a fan of excellent excellent meat
uh well raised carefully raised and wink
is that okay our second sponsor of the
cat is trying to eat the second sponsor
um
a second sponsor is brightmove
brightmove is modern recruiting software
otherwise known as an applicant tracking
system or ats
if you work in a staffing company an rpo
company or an hr department you know
exactly what an ats is and if you're not
using brightmove you are missing out on
the opportunity to make more placements
and hires
brightmove is a bit of an odd sponsor
for us since we don't have any reason to
use the product ourselves we are proud
to be sponsored by prepmove brightmove
however since it was founded in 2004 by
the current ceo david webb brett's
experience with david was that during
unity 2020 he showed up to volunteer
took on a great deal of responsibility
and initiative and planning and crafting
the technical aspects of the ranked
choice voting platform and all of that
was fantastic and he was terrific to
work with
so rightmove's co-founder is mission
aligned with darkhorse but what makes
brightmove the ats vendor for you
they have new software features released
every three weeks the brightmove user
base who are recruiters and hiring
executives themselves are the ones
requesting new features
tech support is 100 us-based and wins
customer service awards every year
recruiting analytics are unique and drag
and drop candidate cards to your hiring
workflow with our with their kanban
style dashboard
for rpo companies there are additional
features that no other recruiting
software can give you a single login for
your company and all customer instances
a global candidate pool to feed all
downstream hiring pipelines data
segregation for compliance and security
per rpo customer security roles for your
team and metrics reported across all
customers
and brightmove includes ip security and
two-factor authentication on all of its
offerings to ensure peace of mind for
business owners and legal teams so if
you use a service like indeed or
ziprecruiter brightmove can supercharge
your hiring by feeding all new jobs to
your internet job boards and then
managing the influx of applicants
helping you filter and sort down to the
best list of people possible
you have to see for yourself why
brightmove is the best applicant
tracking system you've never heard of
until now visit brightmove.com
darkhorse to schedule a software
demonstration today if you become a
customer you will receive one month of
free service depending on your company
size and software package that is a
savings of between a thousand and three
thousand dollars
so visit brightmove.com darkhorse today
that's
b-r-i-g-h-t-m-o-v-e dot com slash dark
horse
and finally
our third sponsor this week is vevo
barefoot shoes made for feet not for
cat's feet you can only see the back of
him at the moment and now you can't see
him at all but for people feeding you're
going to get in trouble if you're going
to have to list all the things that
vivobarefoot are not for well he's
sitting here
he's looking in need not so much of an
applicant tracking system but maybe of
shoes i see i don't want to confuse him
i didn't write exactly it's very
important
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of what feet should be and be
constrained by but vivos vivo barefoots
are made by people who know feet these
shoes are a revelation we love them
they're beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you're
walking on is amazing they cause no pain
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they are fantastic
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution and so are yours
humans evolved to walk move and run
barefoot but modern shoes that are
overly cushioned and strangely shaped
have negatively impacted foot function
and are contributing to a health crisis
one in which people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt
vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up
foot strength increases by 60 in a
matter of months just by walking around
in them the number of people wearing
vivo barefoots is growing once people
start start wearing these shoes they
don't seem to stop it has a great range
of footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
to everyday wear they're certified b
corp pioneering regenerative business
principles and their footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild in it
go to vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get
an exclusive offer of 20 off
additionally all new customers get a 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's
v-i-v-o
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t dot com slash dark horse
so i was um
at this conference which we will come
back to
this conference and uh i was uh sitting
in the audience
trying to glean something from this
panel before
my panel and somebody says uh
dr weinstein it's uh it's very good to
meet you but i
i thought you'd be wearing vivos
uh i had conference
conference shoes yeah i did have
conference shoes on at the time anyway
it hit me and i'll bet your feet weren't
nearly as comfortable as they would have
though
they weren't but i was unlikely to get
canceled over conference shoes that's
what they're for
not being canceled right i think so yes
i suggest a certain willingness to
participate in polite society that's
well but i mean so you have a hypothesis
about neckties yes i do and i feel like
conference shoes may similarly be sort
of a handicapping a like yeah you can't
really you can't really run away that
fast wearing conference shoes and much
less in the idiot shoes that women are
supposed to be wearing which some of us
just won't but um you know the shoes
that you cannot actually make a make a
run for it in
not not totally savvy shoes yeah there
is something to the idea i mean just the
whole idea of a you know a slick soul
and a kind of a confining yeah
it's not it's not the best design for a
shoe so it's interesting how uh how
dominant it is amongst the power players
yes um yeah i i've always kind of
imagined that that was a matter of
constraining you down to something so
similar to everybody else's shoes that
we can figure out how much you spent on
them you know that kind of thing how
long it's been since you've refreshed
them
right and that is a way of telling who
you know what the hierarchy is
economically speaking that's what i
think yeah how high a gloss you can get
your shoes to right i mean if you have
really high quality shoes and they're
very beautiful especially if they change
the fashion slightly so that you also
have you know the right shaped toe and
all of that it says uh you know you're
able to you've got a shoe budget that's
what it says
yeah yeah you've got a shoe budget um
but i can outrun you
right yes
we have a shoe budget but i'm still
going to be alive after this thing
chases us down yes that's yeah that is
true
right so anyway um i don't know where to
start we have three errors to correct we
better do that yeah
i know what one of them is um you want
to start with yours so there's two
the one that you made is from farther
ago and then i made two in the last
episode one in the main episode one of
the q a go for it chronologically i
gotta you just gotta you gotta i've
gotta face the music
all right we're gonna call this
correction that turn for the better all
right yes we are whether you like it or
not even the cat grimaced
tesla grimaced
link grooming is scrimmaging at me but
here's the thing i put up a picture i am
not embarrassed by this picture at all
but we should oh we should have shown
the picture in the picture i thought it
was a turn a picture that i had taken um
in the exhaust zoomas
and uh several astute
bird watchers biologists alerted us that
it was in fact a laughing goal and not a
turn are you actually certain that it
was no laughing girls who contacted us
it was no laughing
was it all people or was it in fact some
members of the clade in question uh
given that everybody's spelling was
better than mine i think it was people
and you know
people have a certain breeding you know
you've met parrots i think they can
spell just fine
um
and they i you know the pronunciation is
often surprisingly good i don't know
about the spelling though
yes um okay so that's your correction
yeah i i i own this one i just got it
wrong yeah yeah no and then the other
two are sort of not in the same vein but
of the same sort of
uh it doesn't matter these are these are
not going to be errors that we are going
to end up politically cancelled over oh
you'd be surprised you know what you do
am i inviting it now you you deliver
these corrections right before takeoff
and then you'll find out hours later
whether you've been canceled especially
if you were ironic that's the thing that
does it in my experience
okay so we were talking about seed oils
and in the last q a and i said that i
thought grape seed and rapeseed oil were
the same thing and they're not
rapeseed is
what is turned into what's called canola
oil and um and grape seed is in fact as
you had posited from grapes
seeds of grapes yes um
yes all right so that's that's the
that's the second correction and then
the third is that i can't actually
remember i didn't go back and look but
for some reason i was invoking the fact
um that when in the field when i when i
used to spend you know many months at a
time living in a tent on an island off
of madagascar sharing at a waterfall etc
watching the sex lives of poison frogs
unfold in front of me
as as
some people did in the 90s mostly me
as i remember it um
that i would take all the reading
material that i could get my hands on oh
i know we were talking about then the
economist
that my wonderful field assistant uh's
parents would send us these care
packages that occasionally included a
block of cheese and often included all
these back issues to the economist but
one of the books that i had taken i said
was crime and punishment and i was so um
i was so impoverished for
uh for the written language that i even
read all of the troop movements which
would have been tough in crime and
punishment there being in fact no troop
movements in crime and punishment and um
what i had actually in high school i had
been lucky enough to have just an
extraordinary
extraordinary great books curriculum and
english curriculum in high school and
had read
a lot of dostoevsky
but i'd never read any tolstoy and so i
had taken war and peace never having
read in fact any tolstoy
to uh to madagascar and i did in fact
read all of the truth movements in war
and peace not in crime and punishment
which would have been a far less
impressive thing to have done would you
care to revisit those troop movements
now it's been a while it's been a while
and i think i now i'm just like i'm
looking past you at all of the books on
this wall and knowing that we have many
other walls in this house that are lined
with books i think i've got plenty at
this point that i would perhaps
skip the troop movements yeah yeah
perhaps yeah okay so yeah those are our
errors uh
tolstoy not dostoevsky uh different
kinds of seed oils and laughing goals
not turns
exactly yeah exactly exactly um so we've
been some places
yeah we have been some places um very
interesting to return to any sort of
traveling postcode
as it warms up here as covet is not
quite banished by seasonality the way
some of us expect it it might be yeah
it's ominous yeah but
nonetheless we've been some places you
and i have been to
so one of the bahamas we went to we so i
have been to four and you have been to
three and together between us we've been
to five different on five different
trips in the last
month plus we've already talked about
the bahamas some which was uh an
extraordinary gift of a of a trip
um
and then i was in austin uh for an event
associated with the university of austin
which i think i mentioned uh in a
previous thing but since we have seen
you last we have been to santa barbara
uh zach and i have been to dc and then
you have been to england including
london and bath
and um
let's just say a little bit about about
each of these and and um
and
really as you say like what
how odd it is to once again be going
places and to feel like
is this
is this like 2019
is this like 2023
will this last
one of the things that you said
uh to me when we were in santa barbara
so we were in santa barbara we were
invited
um to go um by bishop robert baron
who has a podcast and a youtube channel
you know he he he and his people he is a
catholic bishop in gosh i hope i get
this right the archdiocese of los
angeles i believe
who's based in santa barbara and who has
been basically trying to get the word
out and to interact with people not just
who are already um in the fold
with a youtube channel from the very
early days of youtube um and we had you
know off camera we had some really
wonderful conversations with with him
and and some of the people whom he works
with but he had his own he had us on his
show word on fire
word on fire words on fire word on fire
uh and it was it was remarkable i can
say that if you um
got
the description of his position in the
church incorrect i'm pretty sure he will
forgive you i can't tell you how i know
that but it just it's a sense that i
have about him yeah he's he's an
extraordinary man he really is uh and we
my internet has stopped working that's a
really good moment for that to happen
um
we also spent an extra day down there uh
you know we could have flown down and
just had dinner and and spent the night
and gone to his studio and then you know
we had lunch and we had lunch with him
as well and then flowing right back but
we actually spent an extra day so we got
to see a little bit of santa barbara
which i i went to ucsb briefly you know
a couple for a couple years right at the
beginning of my college experience but
ucsb is 12 miles or so
outside of santa barbara and santa
barbara is itself a
very fancy little enclave in southern
california but far enough outside of la
to really have reminded us
almost not at all of la yeah it's like
what la wants to be yeah it's really i
mean you know there's the
vegetation on the hills which is
reminiscent but i really find almost
almost nothing about it yeah similar to
the feeling of l.a but one of the things
you said was it felt like um
it felt like a lot of the people were
missing
yeah and now so now i've had a couple of
trips and i'm i'm
you know it's hard to separate because
two things have happened one the
population
has been through something we've all
been through something together and then
you and i have been through something
that most people
don't have an inkling of
who aren't you know on the wrong end of
and all of that
and so you know one has to separate how
is it is the feeling that is so
different here about what's here is it
about me
what exactly is that but there is a
i would say for me it has been
um
it has been
delightful
eerie and poignant all at the same time
right to travel
again
to see places you haven't done before
and i i
can't say but i feel like this is some
sort of you know
uh
uh an intermission
right between acts of something
which makes it all the more poignant
because
you know to the extent that we have just
discovered how disconnected we can
become from each other how you know
borders that never mattered before like
the canadian border to an american
citizen suddenly become impenetrable
right and if you're canadian and are
unvaccinated you are still um denied
many of your rights right and so
i feel
a couple things one i feel
that um we are traveling in a
transformed world right and that you
know people
i almost felt people are
traumatized they're very relieved you
know every so often you meet somebody
who's been tortured right and they're
out and you think you know you hear the
stories of what they went through and
you think
i just don't even know how a person
processes that
but it is evident that a person can
process it and they can live again and
they can have joy and they can laugh and
all of those things but they are never
the same right you've seen what what can
be done to you
and this isn't that obviously we were
not
uh tortured but we were i think
psychologically you know i i wish we had
you know 40 words for gaslit the way
inuits apparently do not really for snow
but
the apocryphal accounting has it that
they do we need 50 words for gaslit
because this isn't all
of the identical thing but right to the
extent that we are being told that we
must accept nonsense again and again on
a dozen different topics
and then punished if we start asking
questions that is a kind of
um
it is a traumatizing phenomenon and i
believe one can feel it as you travel
someplace yes there's a tentativeness
about people
living yes i i absolutely agree and it's
actually one of the things that was so
um
remarkable about bishop baron and all of
the people whom he is working with on
his team that um you know we
we were invited there as evolutionary
biologists um
to a group of people who have explicit
faith for whom faith is absolutely
central in their lives
and it went in knowing
that on this point we do not see
the world to the same lens
but on so many other points we do
and that the one point on which
you know which could be construed as
utterly fundamental
actually does not preclude us from
conversing and agreeing and
coming to have great respect and
admiration from for one another on so
many other points as in fact i think we
did reveal in the conversation certainly
in the conversations that we had off
camera but i hope in the conversation we
had on camera as well yeah i think
it's really
a lot has been lost recently but this is
one of the things that has been i think
achieved largely in the last five years
um there is a way and i you know i i
hope that we have significantly
contributed to this i think that may be
the case and that's part of why
you know we've been invited to talk to
people such as bishop baron but
there is a recognition
amongst especially people on the
religious side that um
it doesn't have to be that those on the
scientific side are the enemy and in
fact
you know there's a great deal of reason
to think that that's not the case at all
right and it just involves
you know let's put it this way when we
talk about metaphorical truth
we are saying something that could be
read hostilely if you were in you know
if you were of a mindset to view that as
an accusation you certainly could on the
other hand if you have you know
a broad i mean and i think
almost all
thinking religious people have to have a
somewhat broad mindset because they're
living under circumstances that don't
look anything like the circumstances
described in their texts and so you know
that's there's a profound question in
that did god
intend you to live by rules that made a
lot of sense in you know an ancient
world in which nobody spoke the language
you speak or is there some amount of
flexibility is you know is the church a
living entity because it has to be in
order to adjust
you know the religious uh doctrine for
the modern world and so what that means
is not that we come to agreement but
it's like
you know sometimes people ask us
you know they never say it in these
terms but it's sort of like um
[Music]
you know oh
you're an evolutionary biologist well
then how did life begin you know and
it's like well
i gotta tell you really don't know
you know there are some things that make
more sense and some things that make
less sense but that's one of those
things that we might just never find out
because
there's not a whole lot of evidence you
know the evidence is very indirect that
it has been
it has persisted for uh three and a half
billion years
um so anyway the point is all of us have
stuff at the very
very edge of the thing that we care
deeply about
that we may you know effectively have to
be agnostic about and that allows
religious people and and scientifically
focused people
to you know talk about most issues
without ever touching on it absolutely
and i think um you know another thing
that became
more clear for me um associated with
both
um talking with bishop baron and the
other people whom we were talking with
there and just then walking around
talking with you in the aftermath of
that
considering what we had heard and what
we had intuited from what we heard is
that okay
uh be be you in a secular landscape as
we are or in a religious landscape as
they are
you are likely to have in every other
regard all of the same diversity of
opinions
and uh and demographics
and so for instance uh you know we you
know part of how
what happened five years ago this week
when evergreen publicly blew up in a
fury of misplaced outrage and you know
absurd chaos
um was
about the so-called left having lost its
grip on reality in part right and
uh
you know there are there are those of us
and we are certainly not alone who you
know since before then have been saying
actually the best way to go forward into
a future that is as post-racial as
possible is not to keep pointing out how
how bad everyone is to one another based
on race like that's that's not going to
be helpful um and there are those of
course who um say that they're on the
left who say that by saying that you are
demonstrating that you're not on the
left yourself and that you're yourself
um on the right
similarly there will be those on the
right who will say look if you're not
you know if if you
are arguing for anything that sounds uh
like giving in to these people then
you're not really on the right and maybe
you're one of them and i'm like that's
that's much more of a character position
because i don't i don't hear that as
much because we don't claim to be on the
right because we're not
um but i get the sense that um within
the religious community there are people
that are hard right and hard left and
you know woke catholics exist
and
very conservative catholics exist and
there are tensions pulling people in
both directions there just as there are
for those of us who don't exist within
the religious context but are sort of in
in the wider world and so you know the
the
the fight against woke ideology in favor
of an actual liberal understanding of
the world
is not constrained to being one of
either an explicit religious or an
explicitly non-religious context
and that is part of the the lesson of
talking to people who would appear to
have some fundamental difference with
you is where you find all the other
commonalities and all the other ways
that you can actually cross lines and
find ways to talk to them
now
that description
suggests
something to me that i have not
considered before i'm sort of surprised
because thematically it's very much like
many thoughts that i've expressed
but i'm feeling at this moment if you
take our description of much of the
orthodoxy that accompanied the cove
pandemic
as we were described as medically woke
yep
and then you invoked that actually um
with bishop baron i believe yeah and i
must say i invoked the conference too
and people resonate with us for those of
us who
felt this
the analogy was awfully close
you know the conference that you were at
in bath which you haven't introduced
yeah explained yet
um but in any case the question is
in one way
woke is a kind of contagion and
medically woke is a kind of contagion
right it is a set of ideas that spread
horizontally for reasons that are not
about the reality of what's being
described
okay you know contagious mimetic
uh
cluster of ideas and assumptions
but
i guess the question is all right if you
have two
[Music]
earth transforming contagions like this
that come in quick succession
it raises the possibility that these
things are downstream
of a change in the rules
a loss of immunity actually
that would allow such things to catch on
where they would have been tamped down
by normal homeostatic processes in your
culture
beforehand and i guess you could you
could phrase that as a change in the
rules or a release on the idea that
rules are a good idea
and you know the the release on the idea
that i that rules themselves are a good
idea sort of how a lot of the
the woke left is framing their
preferences you know no more police no
more you know no restrictions on people
you're just gonna let them do what
they're gonna do
um so but it's not libertarian it's the
opposite
that's that's the confusing thing about
it it is the suspension of those rules
and it is the imposition of these rules
generated by some
undemocratic anti-democratic
anti-analytical
mechanism that defines the thing right
it's like suddenly you don't have free
speech censorship is good right and what
will be censored is now
the result of some murky process inside
some corporation
that happens completely arbitrarily and
not only or
say our truth or suffer the consequences
yes or you know certain people can say
certain things but other people can't
say the same thing i mean it's just some
sort of impossibly baroque set of new
rules that you that you know their their
defining characteristic is that they're
never spelled out so that you could even
follow them if you wanted to
right or
often there are mutually exclusive sets
of rules uh which you you have to be one
of the chosen ones in order to use these
ones um but you know if you're the
riff-raff then then you're restricted to
these yeah
and those who would make jokes about
recognizing hypocrisy or of course nazis
or something right but it is you know
i guess the question is
it was supposed to be the case that if
you were going to have a major change in
the way we governed ourselves you would
have to talk about it you would have to
convince a certain number of people that
it was a good idea so that the change
that was necessary was made and then
good or bad the new thing would happen
and now it is all bypassed that process
right and it's like you know i'm i'm
constantly struck by the fact
that i go into you know the dmv
and i'm
i'm asked by sex and there are only two
choices and that works pretty well for
me but
i thought i was told pretty well
well enough i mean
let's put it this way i you know my
answer hasn't changed in all of the
years i've had a driver's license i have
noticed right and
my point would be that
either
that is a
spectacular failure of the dmv to keep
up on the latest science
[Laughter]
or
there's some bureaucracy that's just
stodgy enough not to have been afflicted
with this thing i mean
i don't know what it means but you know
even
come on no i don't
i want to hear this
i don't know i don't know what there is
to say i guess my feeling is we're just
caught in a world where you know
somehow the dmv is not constantly beset
by
protesters um
as you might expect based on their
transgression yeah whereas almost any
any survey that you fill out from a
school or uh i would think most sort of
conferences although probably not the
conference you were just at
um and certainly not the little
conference that i was at for the
university of austin but many
many such places will now offer you um
you're not the full panoply of 8 000
possible choices but you know at least
you know a few and then another
and you know maybe a space to fill in
your explanation from that you could
leave you are you need male female and
don't go their girlfriend
yeah right
but i mean as as douglas murray has has
said uh and this this is one of his uh
what is one of his framings one of his
many framings that i really appreciate
um so much of
those things are actually it's not don't
go there girlfriend it's look at me
right you know so so many of the
of the neologisms maybe that's not even
the right word here but uh because they
don't actually describe a real thing but
like the the the ways that we are told
and you know now they're doing with the
pride flag apparently like there's not
nearly enough colors in the world to
describe all the ways to be and so
they're just adding lines and lines and
chevrons and this that the other the
pride flag and it's it's about look at
me it's like this you know this is this
is the way that people
imagine they're finding meaning in the
world yeah and um you know maybe just to
to go back i'm thinking about our time
just walking around walking around and
biking around a little bit in santa
barbara and seeing people like you said
it didn't seem like there were as many
people as we would have expected
but
we were walking in like a dining
district where we stopped for cocktails
one place and we stopped for dinner
another place and
people just looked
like they were having a good time
they just they looked
in in that place no one was masked there
were families out there were couples out
there were uh older people out there
were all sorts of people of all the
demographic descriptions out and they
just looked to be enjoying themselves
yes but i don't well you and i may have
perceived it differently i did not feel
that they were enjoying themselves
um
without the thing that they had been
through effectively
haunting it like like waiting for the
next shooter you know in the meantime
we're happy to be out here in the sun
yeah but at any moment
you know
i think we have all lost confidence that
we will be you know free people choosing
what we're going to do because we
actually know better now
yes and in which case i would hope that
that doesn't that that awareness as that
awareness fades it becomes more and more
possible it will happen again and soon
right
that
the the greater awareness we have like
wait
many of us just signed off on having a
bunch of our rights taken away and then
in trying to get them back we are told
that maybe they weren't ours to begin
with or something like what
what was that how did that happen right
how did that happen and
you know
one of the things that haunts me
is
we have to now live with each other
let's say that the thing recedes and it
doesn't return in the fall
and you're talking now not about the uh
the human
infrastructure but the virus well i'm
talking about
the
radical decrease in our freedoms that we
experienced which we were told you know
two weeks to flatten the curve and then
it just kept extending and new things
were added and
and all of that
so i don't want to limit this i don't
want to limit this to you know covid
right
um i but to the extent that next fall
arrives and we do not see a sudden
emergency radical constraining of our
freedom so you're talking about like
this
this northern temperate fall september
shows up yeah
should that happen
then we will for a time
at least
have to go back to some sort of normal
pattern of interacting which is on the
one hand great except
we have now seen what happens when the
thing
comes
and people have had very different
reactions and they've played very
different roles right so we have to go
back to being a functional society
when you know some of us have for
example been demonized as the cause of
the pandemic right pandemic of the
unvaccinated
right
knowing that your society can do that to
you at the drop of a hat and very
wrongly
right
how exactly do we you know is there a
mechanism is there a truth and
reconciliation mechanism i mean forget
the powers that be is there a truth and
reconciliation mechanism that even
allows
us as peers to navigate something that
we will trust as a relationship with
people who have
you know taken up arms against us as if
we were exposing
the world to
to pathogens right i don't know um
but
in any case i
i think i mean i i hate this but i think
i think our listeners will hear me
struggling to describe some
visceral experience of traveling and
then interacting with people
um
that just as pleasant as it is
it's not normal
right you know and some of that is
undoubtedly my perception but some of
that is likely not some of that is the
fact that people have been through
something profound and they are
grappling with how to understand it and
one of the things that it was very
aggressive about doing was disrupting
our ability to make sense of things and
disrupting our ability to
find our way to a consensus about what
took place by discussing it with each
other right what took place is going to
be something that will be told to us and
we will either accept it or reject it
and the people who rejected are the bad
people right that's that's the pattern
and
um so anyway i
i don't know where we are but i
definitely
um
it is it is hard to walk around even in
a perfectly delightful place i found
bath surprisingly delightful i was not
maybe it's just my ignorance and some
hole in my education but i did not
realize what bath was before i got there
and upon arriving
you know i discovered a
beautiful place with ancient roots and
very pleasant to walk around and quite
clean and you know just a really
interesting part of you thought a place
named bath would not be clean
uh well to be honest with you i did not
know that bath was a i mean not all
baths are clean but um did not know that
that was a literal reference to
something um and so i thought it was
just some uk township um it's it's not
it's a it's a
tourist center it's a so do you i i do
want to talk about dc a bit but i can i
can save that i can go out of order
chronologically if you want to talk
about the conference first we can do it
either way i mean mostly at the moment
i'm just remarking on the experience of
being elsewhere and um
being haunted by the
appearance of normalcy or semi-normalcy
and the feeling of not normal
um so what do you think dc or
it's up to you
all right let's talk about dc we'll do
it chronologically okay
so the morning after we got back from
santa barbara
zach and i flew to dc
and uh i
i did not prepare a full sort of
explanation of what what all we were
doing there but uh zach i hope that you
will correct me if my very brief uh
summary here is is wrong okay
uh so last year zach led his uh high
school rocketry team to winning the
national
uh rectory competition tarc which stands
for the american rocketry competition i
think
challenge challenge
uh and
what's that
it might be challenge might be
competition okay uh and
uh
the
uh the founder of the of the high school
rocketry team that uh zach was
led to uh led to winning last year uh
had graduated the year before
he was a mentor on the team um last year
and he had really and then um largely
passed the baton to zach
created all sorts of remarkable um
active programs uh with regard to the
rocket so they've got active descent and
they've got active async is that right
zach or am i saying that wrong
yeah um i mean i know i know that active
ascent is a thing but i thought there
might be a special a special language
for it um and so there's a tremendous
amount of
both coding and circuit circuit board
building and also hardware design and
um in this case at the very last minute
there was a new parachute design you
know just a tremendous amount of work
that put in that allowed for a
tremendous amount of precision
and um and we went out to um
the plains virginia is that what it was
called the great meadow
have you described what the precision is
for
the competition tests the competition
test it changes every year um and um
there are specs around um how
how large the rocket can be it can't be
over it was like 650 grams i make that
up okay and this year it had to hold two
eggs and they had to land safely
and then for the finals there were two
uh two launches um
the first of which had to be so correct
me if i'm wrong zach i'm doing this for
memory i think to um 610 feet
of course 810 feet and have a flight
time between 41 and 43 seconds
40 and 43 seconds and then the second
flight
had to go to 850 feet and be between 42
and 45 seconds
860 42 and 45 seconds okay and uh for
each um
foot that you're off of the uh of the
apogee of the flight um you get a point
and for every second that you're outside
of the window you get five points and a
score of zero is perfect and so you want
the lowest score possible
and um and their first their flight um
can i can i interject a couple things
here of course of course okay so yeah
the key thing is that in order to reach
that height you could basically if you
imagined a perfectly static world right
you could figure out uh
what weight and drag
coupled with the particular motor these
motors are highly standardized they're
not perfect would get you that height
and approximately that descent time
based on how big a parachute and under
with you know as you say with no wind
under certain pres right it's not like
metric pressure like if you've designed
the rocket and are flying in exactly the
same conditions and get the same
so you can understand the same rocket
will
deliver different results based on uh
all sorts of all sorts of things
but a rocket that can measure where it
is right can actually as it is going to
exceed its uh flight ceiling can add
drag by kicking out some breaks right
and as it's descending you have
zach your current rocket has uh motors
that
oh you're using exclusively the
parachute reefing so
last year they had
propellers
that could add drag to slow the descent
and just
and this year they used a system in
which the parachute could be pulled back
in to speed the descent or let back out
in order to slow the descent so you can
imagine a rocket that knows how high it
is
right and uh
can deploy these things is capable of
getting much closer to hitting those
numbers perfectly
than a rocket in which it's just simply
based on um the basic parameters of the
rocket and the motor and you know cross
your fingers yep absolutely so having
both active ascent and active descent
systems
on board and um another one of the rules
is that you cannot interact with
anything about the rocket from the
ground so you can't be you know in
inputting any information um once once
it's launched it's launched and it's
going to do what it's going to do
um so as last year's winner they went
first
and uh they hit 858 feet in 45 seconds
which would have been a nearly perfect
flight it would have been a two-point
flight which is extraordinary
but the first flight was supposed to be
for the 810.
so and that was due to one little piece
of code not being put into comment
rather than um being being um
not not being commented and so it ran
rather than the
810 um script
make that slightly clearer if you're
programming and you have a parameter
that you might swap out so the program
remains the same but the parameter swaps
out you can comment out you can turn
into a comment which the thing that
reads the program ignores the value that
you're not using anymore and you can put
in your new value and in this case a
punctuation error left the old value
active so the rocket performed
exactly as the rocket thought it should
perform
but it was the wrong flight so
completely heartbreaking they obviously
didn't win they didn't come close um but
uh
and i've asked zach to um to take me out
maybe you out this weekend i want i want
to see the two flights um
and you know
the rocket did exactly what was supposed
to do and it did so with elegance and
precision and zach talked to some of the
other um some of the other people who
were there afterwards
who were just geeking out over the
engineering and the rocketry and it's
just a joy to see people actually
really caring deeply about physical
systems and engineering and problem
solving and going oh i had an idea like
that but i wasn't sure how to bring it
to realization and having this go back
and forth between people in real time
it's just like this is what discovery
and engineering and
and science also is supposed to be about
and it's amazing and you know a
heartbreaking result at one level but um
really really amazing another
as a result zach and i were there okay
so we were there and um
we took uh there there are a couple
things worth commenting about the trip
other than uh the tarc competition
which is probably redundant target
competition it's like having steak with
those juice right yes yeah um
of the day
yeah
um
one is uh we were out i don't know an
hour sort of east of dc
and we went to get some breakfast in
warrenton virginia we don't
neither of us zach had never been in the
dc area at all uh i have been a few
times once as a kid and a couple times
more recently
and um
and i just looked up like breakfast near
me and it was you know ways away from
where we were but the closest to that
looked reasonable and so we drove on
saturday morning into the town of
warrenton
and we couldn't make the left that
google mouse was telling me i should
make at the rental car
because it was blocked
there's a police blockage and we had to
drive through
one side of the street was black lives
matter protest and the other side of the
street was an all lives matter protest
and
uh it was
fascinating to drive through and then i
realized after we had parked in this
sort of quaint little town in the middle
of what seemed to me like nowhere oh
we're gonna actually have to walk back
through this this protest and that
that'll be interesting
and
and i wrote about this also in this
evergreen piece that i wrote for natural
selections this week um
we ended up on the side of the street
just because of where the restaurant was
uh with the oil lives matter protesters
and talked to a couple of them
and
while we were talking to a couple of
them one of the other all lives matter
protesters started just
kind of throwing a fit and yelling and
he was standing in the street and he was
yelling at the black lives matter
protesters
and zach and i are saying to the two
people we're talking to who are very
calm
and you know we're making frankly in
many ways a lot of sense he said that's
not helping that's not helping anyone
here but it's certainly not helping you
send the message uh that you're actually
interested in
everyone moving forward into the future
with some
you know some some freedom and justice
uh but of course all movements have
their unhinged people and in this case
the unhinged person happened to be on
the side of all lives matter and that
was it's unfortunate whenever it's it
shows up anywhere but that that was the
case there
we talked uh to these uh to these people
and they were they seemed you know
honorable and
um they were they were faithful they uh
in fact one of them was quoting
scripture at me which i didn't find
compelling as an argument for why all
lives should matter but you know any
more than i find
appeals to authority when it's from the
cdc compelling on their own
but it was
fascinating
to also observe that if you just took
like nice mug shots like if you tried to
do like profile portraits of the people
the black lives matter protesters looked
more like
people that i see in the coffee shops
around here who i imagine i might have
more in common with who you know
probably think about eating locally and
eating organic and probably want to
spend a lot of time outside
and all of this and
and yet
the things that they were chanting were
the usual black lives matter chants that
i know to either be not what they claim
or to actually be inconsistent with
other things that they chant given
what's been on their website and you
know and much of which they've taken
down
but you know all of this is happening in
a sort of uh an excerpt of dc you know
an hour out of dc like very far outside
uh
but in a context that i didn't i never
foresaw i never imagined that we would
run into
black lives matter and all lives matter
protesters uh in warrington virginia and
then we went back the whole team went
back and you know i and one of the other
parents the other parent who was an
actual chaperone and
the team
like the person from the school who's
like the mentor sort of um
went back to like a what was it called
carousel zack the the sweet shop
um which was its own cultural
extravaganza uh and i thought ah this
just reminds me of nothing i've ever
seen before this is like this is the
place where everyone in the town comes
for saturday night and gets desserts
that i don't recognize even as food and
none of the other sort of portland kids
were like i don't it's it's a deep fried
twinkie is it okay i'm not sure i want
to eat that
um
so the whole thing was a little bit like
traveling to a different country in some
regards and then to have sort of people
from a different country but still with
the black lives matter and the all lives
matter people facing off against one
another and yelling at one another
okay so there was that
and then the next day we went um i'd
gotten us an airbnb for the night in dc
and we went first to arlington
which was super easy to be in you know
arlington had all the little cafes and
the good cappuccinos and all the stuff
that uh you know that that i think i
like and it was just easy to walk but
they had great bagels right zach
and then in dc
we had um
let's see i sent you three pictures
right zach yeah you want to show um
first scotus
so we walked by the supreme court
uh
and
it was on a this was a monday morning
so i guess it's the next this next
morning it was a gray morning there
there was clearly a lot of signs of um
there having been
protests over the weekend but uh while
we were there there was this one lone
protester
uh who had a backpack on from which she
was blaring some sort of very angry
music
and i can't read it from here but her
sign says something like
you know she's she's pro-choice
right um but then the other signs which
again i can't read i wonder if you could
put it on our little screen here zach
no you can't well maybe you can so i i
don't remember what's on the signs but
the one that's most yep
yeah so just just tell us what one of
them one of them says here
okay um
rights start at conception
and gay rights started conception and
then i think the one lying on the ground
says something like
um
atheists for life
and all three of those signs
are
just not what we were expecting
and they speak to some protests that
i've yet seen yet to see any evidence of
elsewhere
and the idea you know trans rights begin
at conception
this causes so many errors to be thrown
right away that it's really hard to even
know what to think and you know maybe
the point was
whoever whoever designed that sign and
was carrying it was trying to throw
errors in the in the minds of the of
pro-choice protesters um or they were
just themselves very confused or i don't
even know what but this you know this is
the supreme court of the united states
everyone that's a perfect perfect uh
indicator of the level of confusion of
the moment almost no matter what
explains it yeah yeah yeah
um so i guess actually the night before
then um the next picture zach is of the
rainbow over the white house
uh which we saw uh if you can show it
yeah um
we were
we had gone to the um national portrait
gallery
which was
uh fascinating there's a watergate
exhibit at the moment which is um quite
worth seeing and we walked through the
presidential portraits
and we're learning some things i had
been there back right when the obama
portraits had had gotten there and
they're now on the move so they weren't
there
so it went uh so so there weren't so
barack obama wasn't there and there is i
imagine a sort of temporary one for
trump there but the uh
the bios they have one or two paragraph
bios for all of the presidents and the
farther back you go
um the
the clearly less politicized excuse me
they are but they all seem pretty
straightforward they all seem to pretty
much describe the facts
until you get to trump and i wish i'd
taken a picture or you know i could tell
you exactly what it said but
uh you know as as we've said here before
um i'm not a fan of trump and vote for
him
i didn't uh vote for the other guy in
the last election either but um i did i
i haven't voted for him
and
the description of him
on in the national portrait gallery was
so politicized and so not reflective of
actually a description of what it is
that he did as president
and
any fair
analysis of the things that he
accomplished includes some things that
all americans should be able to get
behind no such things are mentioned and
what is mentioned is january 6th and i'm
not do you remember zach if the word
insurrection is used i don't remember
and i don't want to i don't want to
misquote
i don't remember exactly the word
yeah
so
that that struck me as a tragic
disappointment in one of our most
important national museums to have it be
politicized in this way when this is
supposed to be about portraits of
presidents yeah in fact it's
um
[Music]
decidedly unwelcoming of some large
fraction of the electorate which half
the electorate this has become this has
become the nature of
our system which is
at least on the one side
there is
a sort of sense that people who disagree
are
not entitled to the full rights of
citizens they're not entitled to have
their president um objectively
memorialize that you know it's it's
preposterous how could this how could
this possibly end well yeah no it's it's
not it's not okay it's not okay
um
so from there we we walked and we walked
to dinner and then we got sort of stuck
in a thunderstorm and we we uh got told
we needed to leave from in front of the
white house and it seemed like something
interesting might happen and so zach and
i hung out there for a while and nothing
interesting happened but we did see this
rainbow and then we and then
we stayed there long enough to miss the
sunset into onto the lincoln memorial
but we got there um a few minutes after
the sunset and that's that's just an
extraordinary monument
um
and we also went to
what it's called
what's that crazy museum called zack uh
sorry i hate to do this right here it's
the udvar hazy center the basically the
overflow museum for the air and space
museum which was closed right now but
it's got
it's got a concord it's got the enola
gay it's got a blackbird it's got uh
some of the very early planes it is oh
it's got the discovery the space shuttle
the whole discovery uh and
uh i it was hard to find political
signage in the udvar-hazy center uh
which was um outside of dc
uh and that that was an extraordinary
museum highly recommended as well
conservatives are still welcome in the
aviation museum apparently that must be
some kind of oversight maybe due to uh
the recognition that
they too use physics
i'm
not willing to concede any such thing
so um just just a couple more things
about our experience in dc
the last morning that we were there we
went well we went past scotus i really
wanted to see the library of congress
and it turns out they weren't open that
day so we got to the door of the library
congress and they weren't open um
but we did go to
the
um
museum of african american history which
um i had gone to in more depth a few
years back and found it really
extraordinary and then we also went to a
museum that um none of us had been to
before and now zach and i have been we
went to the holocaust museum
and so that the last picture zach for
you to show
is something that many people who who
are aware
of the museum and
of the history know but um these are
some just some
some of the
millions i think of shoes
um of the people who were killed
during the holocaust
just in piles and piles and piles and
there's something about the numbers
that the human mind can't grasp and
seeing actual
shoes that were worn by actual people
who cease to exist
due to
evil acts of genocide
really takes the breath away
yes i have not been to that museum but i
very much hope to go
uh
i
hope to go makes me sound like i doubt i
will get to dc again but um
yeah anyway yeah i'm looking forward to
going yeah
so zach and i got back from there
uh late late late and the very next day
you flew
yeah
to england to england yeah um yeah so
why don't i
i'll just say that
um
england felt
very different i've been to england
quite a number of times it has not been
so exciting having seen it many times
this time it was
quite poignant i think as a result of
having been disconnected from the world
and just simply
um seeing seeing a culture that is
surprisingly different i mean you know i
think one forgets how different it is
um was remarkable but okay i went to
bath and this conference
was um
a conference of
primarily coveted dissidents of one form
or another it was organized
by
tess laurie and her group whose name i
always forget
um
but in any case
uh i was doing some presenting at this
conference and i was doing some hosting
of panels the conference was quite uh
eclectic in terms of who who was there i
did get to meet quite a number of uh
people who
strangely you and i have been in battle
alongside many of these people but have
only met some of them
in person
and it was
almost indescribably um
what's the word it was uh comforting
just to meet them in person right
garrett vandenbosch was there ryan cole
who actually doesn't live so far from us
he's in idaho um he's a pathologist he's
a pathologist i will return to him
shortly i found what he had to say
remarkable um
uh
i got to meet uh phil harper who we had
not met before
so in any case oh and uh i had not met
tess lori we certainly interacted over
zoom but
anyway to be in the company of all of
these people who have been fighting in
parallel against the same
amorphous
well-resourced diabolical enemy and i
hate to describe it in those terms but
the way it behaves
leaves no doubt on the part of those who
have been targeted by it that there is a
something i don't know how it works i
don't know how many organizations are
collaborating but you know we do know
that uh gavi exists the trusted news uh
initiative exists
we know that the cdc has dictated a
certain amount the who um so anyway
there are these organizations and they
clearly share a perspective and they
clearly target people who step out of
line
so in any case
something indescribable about meeting
these people
um oh neil oliver was there also i must
say that was
uh quite cathartic to meet him in person
and uh you know look him in the eye and
um
to just
you know the joy of discovering that
such a person exists for those of you
who don't know neil oliver you probably
do know him you've probably seen a
soliloquy or two
um
distributed on twitter
um but he's really he's really a lovely
person but in any case i just wanted to
give a few
um
of the insights
from the conference
i think the one that struck me most
was hearing from people who have been
vaccine injured being able to talk to
them privately so they were
presentations but you know also being
able to talk to these people privately
and just get a sense not only for what
they've been through
um medically
but maybe even more importantly what
they have been through in the aftermath
of
having their injuries
like socially
yes
and
i think you know there are a lot of
things about this last
year that have been
utterly jaw-dropping but i think the one
that sticks with me
most the thing that i'm going to have
the hardest time
uh forgetting
is
the gaslighting of people who did what
they were asked to do
and were injured in the process
now let's say and then we
were
treated as despicable
liars or
or
non-existent
right right how
how dare you have been injured how dare
you talk about it
how dare you
bring this to anyone's attention don't
you see that you're part of the problem
right and and the insanity is so deep
that in general one of the things that
these people most frequently hear is
that they are anti-vaxxers right these
are people who took the vaccine and were
injured by it and then are accused of
being
anti-vaxxers
they are effectively denied care they're
told that it's in their minds they're
doctors who do know how to treat them
paul america in particular
um
[Music]
delivers a very compelling i mean you
know tears in his eyes he says i'm faced
with these people
i know how to treat them but i'm not
allowed to right his hands have been
tied to hear that story
i guess the point is
what kind of civilization i mean even
let's say that the vaccines were
exceedingly safe right and the
occasional person got severely injured
right as far as i'm concerned that
person
is
a hero right they got the short straw in
a thing that they did for everybody
everybody did their part these people
came up with a short straw they are
entitled to an extraordinary level of
care they're entitled to better care
than most people have because their
injury comes from doing something they
participated in something that was
ostensibly to
foster our collective well-being yeah it
feels a little bit um maybe this is a
bad analogy but as you're talking it
reminds me of
how vietnam vets were treated when they
came back it's exactly the thought right
you sign up because your government says
your country needs you
something terrible happens to you you
need care you come back you can't your
mind doesn't accept that you are now at
peace and
you can't live a normal life
how is it that these people are not
receiving extraordinary care and why do
we not compare
how these people are treated like all
sorry all war vets but
the vietnam war vets were treated
particularly brutally but it's
particularly bad because society had no
patience for that war by the end right
right
but
nonetheless it seems to me that at the
point on the front end of their
recruiting effort where they're saying
hey your country needs you sign up it's
really important right the first
question ought to be well how are you
going to treat me if it doesn't go well
yeah what happens if
what happens if i do what you say and i
end up severely harmed by it are you
still going to be there and if the
answer that question is no then the
answer is sorry that's not the deal if
my country needs me then my country
should take care of me if it doesn't go
well right right and so
these people
responded to the call these people now
you're talking about the people that was
the vaccine the vaccine responded to the
call and frankly
if you we are going to be blamed despite
the fact that you and i are
vaccine enthusiasts that a book written
before covet happened lists vaccines as
one of the three great medical
discoveries right though that's who we
are and we're demonized as anti-vaxxers
right how many anti-vaxxers do you
create when you injure people with a
vaccine and then pretend they're not
hurt right how many people is that going
to drive rightly drive away analytically
drive away i'd be crazy if they're
talking about this what else are they
lying about right and if they're
treating me like this over what is
happening now
who else has experienced what that i
don't know about yes
it's very very safe really
totally safe yes totally safe and if it
turns out that it hurts me does that
mean you that you will then take care of
me no we're going to treat you like
garbage right it's like yeah i i can't
believe that we can't just simply see
how the dots connect right so
i guess i i am
beyond fed up right the the gaslighting
of people who spoke up was terrible the
gaslighting of people who did what they
were asked and were harmed by it and
some of them severely harmed right that
is unconscionable it's unconscionable
and
i guess i would ask others right those
who just wish this topic would go away
are you okay with that right yeah maybe
you took the vaccine maybe it went well
are you okay with people who made the
same choice that you did and will never
live a normal life again being treated
like this by the governments that asked
them to do it that asked you to do it
you're really okay with that i can't
imagine how you could be
um so there's that
i will also say i think ryan cole the
pathologist
has a special role to play and i'm
troubled that there seems to be only one
of him
right only one pathologist who is
speaking publicly about what he's seeing
right now maybe i'm wrong about that but
i haven't when you were talking to me as
you know you just came home yesterday um
as you know yes
um but when you were trying to when you
were sort of giving me a quick overview
of of of what you had seen and
experienced and everything there
my question to you was where are all the
other pathologists right and i don't
think we know the answer to that
question um it is especially troubling
you know it could be that you wouldn't
the pathologists aren't seeing anything
aren't seeing anything yet but that
can't be right right so what is i don't
i don't know what you're free to talk
about what you understand from dr cole
well if if you are you might share
somewhere so for those of you who
haven't thought about what a pathologist
is a pathologist is a
doctor who sees
specimens
but not patience right this is somebody
whose specialty is looking i hope ryan
if i have this slightly wrong that
you'll uh gently reach out and i will
correct it but
basically the point is this is you know
how a radiologist is a doctor you never
see the doctor looks at the scans or the
mris or whatever it is that you've got
and says aha that shadow there is a
something or other well the pathologist
is somebody who's looking it's like
blood cultures and tissue cultures
cultures biopsies all sorts of stuff so
they see this and what this means
for a pathologist you know
ryan cole has
many years of experience behind the
microscope right he's there for the
beginning of covid he's there for
the vaccine program and what he's doing
he's and he's there decades before right
like i don't know how old he is but at
least like many many years many years
before
so
in that time you will see
transitions in how many of this type of
cancer you see and that type of cancer
and this type of dysfunction that type
of dysfunction and so the point is this
is a doctor who sees way more patients
than most so if a doctor you know
because he doesn't see whole people he
sees samples right exactly and so you
know he has a much larger data set than
most people do and he's in a position to
see change in a way that if you were a
doctor in an office seeing patients you
might see that change but you wouldn't
necessarily know whether it was noise
right it's just a sample size is lower
it's just harder than that just harder
to know right so he's seeing all these
things including
lots of cancers very sudden cancers
right cancers that were dormant and then
suddenly are in stage four this kind of
thing
um you know and
he is
profoundly altered by
looking at the change in what patients
are facing and his own profession and
their
ignoring of these patterns which
i don't know what we do about it because
with one pathologist it's very hard for
this point to be successfully made
but
it's a very
his report is very stark
and it is consistent with the other
doctors right there's a lot of doctors
at this conference including you know so
did you did you specify the the timing
maybe i was thinking about something
else you were saying but do you specify
are you free to specify the timing of
when he starts seeing
an explosion of
of of cancers i don't think i know
although he has spoken about it publicly
there's actually um
an interview clip that people will
probably have seen on twitter where he's
seated i believe he's seated with books
behind him and he is discussing these
cancers that he is suddenly seeing
uh emerge well the question is is this
attributable to covet or vaccines or
both
um i believe well i'm going to leave
that to ryan i'm going to interview him
but
yeah fabulous yeah no i think it's a
it's a must do um he is certainly seeing
a lot of pathology that he believes is
vaccine in nature and he would be in a
position to know because the difference
between 2020 and 2021 is the vaccines
that's right um
all right so that was a uh
an important upshot i will say for those
of you who are inclined to demonize this
as some kind of an anti-vaxx conference
i will i think ultimately all of the
video from the conference is going to
emerge so you will be interested on the
panel that what i believe it was the
first panel and it was uh moderated by
majid noise
there was an interesting back and forth
between
um it started out between
dell big tree
and garrett vandenbosch and what
happened was dell big tree actually
queried the audience on the panel
about whether they felt that vaccines
had an important role to play in public
health and
robert malone garrett vandenbosch and
myself robert malone and garrett van
bush both being vaccinologists and me
being an evolutionary biologist all said
yes
um and we had a back and forth with dell
about it so this was not an anti-vaxx
conference what this was is a conference
in which people who are uh vaccine
hesitant and from before covid
uh we're in dialogue with people who are
very pro-vaccine and very troubled by
what's happened
uh during covid anyway i think that
that's really interesting i will also
say it was one of the things
people in the
audience responded to i must have had
25 or 30 people come up to me and say
they were really glad to see that
exchange right they really thought that
this needed to be aired because it's too
easy for
camps to become entrenched and the
dialogue needs to happen
um so that was really important
um people are uh
eager
to see
respectful disagreement
they and it's not you know it's not
blood thirst
it's
i've had no exposure to it and i know
that there are reasons
and there are reasons that you might
land on either side of this and i really
want to hear what smart people have to
say in response i want to build up my
model and build up my arsenal if you
will and maybe you know using that kind
of language isn't helpful here but you
know people act this is how you learn
how to com how to compose arguments and
how to engage with people when you do
run into people who who don't agree with
you is by hearing how other people do it
and you can do it from scratch you know
you can't figure it out from scratch but
it is
every time you or i or we have been
involved in something like that where
there's actual disagreement
and it doesn't just result in yelling
uh people are appreciative they're
appreciative and they are also
appreciative of
the sense
that
i don't know how to phrase it exactly
but watching people respectfully
disagree
over substance analytical substance is
reassuring because so many people have
had the experience of you know
expressing let's say skepticism of the
coveted vaccines and then having all
hell break loose in their life right
that just simply seeing that actually at
the end of the day they're not crazy and
this is an analytical question
is super
uh important right that's a reaction
shot where zach leaves the camera on you
while i'm talking so that we can see how
you feel about me which is cool because
i think you feel pretty good about me
but yeah
okay that's good
um
so okay i wanted to add a couple things
um
the garrett vandenbosch
feature of this was
important and i feel certain based on
the way people
commonly
yes we have a helicopter problem i don't
know if you can i think that's actually
an airplane but yeah that actually is
but we do have a helicopter problem
yeah
yeah i don't love the fact that we have
a helicopter problem we never used to
it'll go away you know
breeding season they'll fly off
somewhere else
um all right so garrett vandenbosch
predicted on this program i will point
out i mean it wasn't the first place he
had done it but he predicted that we
would have a pandemic of
variance yes he also predicted that the
severity of those variants uh would go
up and he predicted that it would move
in the direction
of younger people
now i believe he was right on two of
these three counts the bracketing too
right like not the middle one uh the
variance certainly proliferated
um
and the uh level of contagiousness went
up the level of severity seems to have
gone down okay so you just split up his
second one into two parts so three out
of four perhaps your virulence has gone
up but severity's gone down and then the
third one is you described it which is
actually the fourth one
um
in the new variants is that you think
that you are seeing and i also think
that i'm seeing although i've seen data
on it per se is that this is affecting
young people more and more yeah
um yeah the virulence is actually the
severity so it's the contagiousness
that's gone up the virulence has gone
down um at least so far which doesn't
mean that it will continue to but
uh in any case the the point i want to
make is
p
gear took a lot of crap for his view
that the vaccine program was going to
cause a proliferation of variance and
that it was going to make the thing more
contagious and more damaging
and my point would be
you don't get out of it right now that
he's turned out to be right when
somebody has a prediction that turns out
to be right you don't get to make a
special pleading now it's possible that
he could have gotten there by accident
but unless you predicted better than he
did right then the question is what
model did you use to predict that and
what does it say is coming next and the
problem is that the model that he used
to predict that has some very dire
things to say about what's coming right
more variance vulnerability amongst the
vaccinated primarily
and
severe disease so
nobody including knows whether that is
going to happen but i would say when
somebody who has done as good a job of
predicting the course of the pandemic as
garrett says that we don't have a choice
but to listen right this is this is
somebody who has demonstrated that he's
got a model that works better than than
the field and
um
i would say i am at least
paying very close attention to what he
has to say it's um
it's
quite frightening and hopefully
hopefully he's uh incorrect about it but
nonetheless
um i don't know buckle your seat belts i
guess oh boy yeah yeah
um
so i'll just say it's um 605. yep um
there's a
a lot of other things that aren't
exactly in this territory that we're
thinking about doing but we're going to
be back in less than 48 hours so i think
we should save some of okay what we were
talking about but but you may not be
done yet um
we can we can leave it there for the
moment i may return to a couple of
topics from the conference later on but
i do feel like we've
we've more or less set the stage and
most of what i was hoping to accomplish
was to give people a sense of um what
the feeling
was being there
and
anyway i hope you all find
comfort there was a lot of comfort for
people who attended as as
spectators or as participants just
simply in being in the company of that
many people
who
were at least holding on to sanity yeah
well and i guess we probably should have
said at the top of the hour too i hope
this isn't a secret but it's about not
to be um is that you recorded several in
fact five
um darkhorse episodes while you were
there with people who were there some of
whom you've mentioned here each one
darker than the last
okay
which are going to be released weekly on
on tuesdays i think for for the next
well five weeks
so those i'm looking forward to hearing
them and i think you were
um you were very enthusiastic about the
conversations as you were having them
yes i will also say i recorded an
unheard episode with freddie sayers
while i was in london on my final day
that i think is out today or if it's not
out today it'll be out tomorrow so you
might check that out i was
pretty good he uh you know he pulled no
punches but um anyway i thought the
interview was was what was good and i
think people
will enjoy that too wonderful
um so i forgot to bring it up but on
saturday at uh noon 30 pacific time on
saturday we'll be back and we'll do an
episode then and we'll do a q a which we
haven't done in a while
um and we'll also bring up the uh the
french version of a hunter gatherer's
guide to the 21st century which we just
got delivered to us uh yesterday and
we'll show you back
treble indeed and um and the spanish
version's about to come out we haven't
not received those yet but um
but uh for those we have been hearing
from people uh who are eager for the
book in both french and spanish and
there are other the lithuanians coming
out there's all sorts of stuff
in both french and spanish i mean i am
really you're not going to read them
simultaneously i'm not
honestly probably going to read either
of them because neither my french nor my
spanish is that good but i'm sure it
would improve if i tried to read both my
spanish and my french would improve i
tried to read our book in spanish and
french anyway um
oh there's probably a lot more to say
here but i think we are going to sign
off
and um say thank you for for being here
again subscribe to this that and the
other channel this being you know
youtube and odyssey and the dark horse
podcast clips channel
and uh like the episode share the
episode share clips uh get get the word
out if you are enjoying this and we know
that many people are because we hear
from a lot of you and we appreciate that
in the meantime until we see you next
which is again in less than 48 hours be
good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside fight the
good fight
[Music]
[Music]
you